donc vous connaissez le portrait chinois
si j'étais une fleur je serai un mieux
au titre bon ça c'est l'anti portrait
chinois par exemple si vous étiez une
injure il a une très belle dans full
flush de sam shepard c'est pour moi pas
de ta mère de koor si vous étiez une
maladie la syphilis
c'est que j'étais un accident une
rupture d'anévrisme
parce que ça arrive brutalement comme ça
c'est un mec c'est dans mes interne une
perversion
se ronger les ongles jeudi à une guerre
une quartier visé une révolution vous
étiez avis le voyeurisme juste une
trahison
l'adultère une arme une arme blanche
supplice les supplices défend morceau
c'est quoi il ya une photo dont les
larmes d'eros de bataille avec un
chinois qui sera découpé en morceaux et
on va son regard
tazi policier que vous êtes découvert
bataille l'âge de 15 ans ouais ouais et
dans viande cédant viande ou il ya pis
alors j'ai dit est dédié à pierre
angélique c'est ça je vous dis une
cicatrice vous étiez un poison la
digitaline ce que guy bach suicider avec
la digital hier et il en faut 60 votes
pour mourir donc comme un jeu si vous
étiez une [ __ ]
voilà non j'hésite entre lady macbeth
monica levinsky que les mamans ou
verifix fait du mal pour rien si vous
étiez à l'impôt de droits de succession
si vous étiez une table ne pas savoir
répondre à une de vos questions
un dictateur dieu une infirmité
l'incontinence nasa
sid ahmed rezala j'ai écrit une pièce
sur lui avant si vous étiez à microbes
un colibacille si vous étiez un
terroriste je sais pas encore ce qu'on
avait quelques unes voilà toutes les
semaines ça n'existe pas encore s'ils
étaient en vacances le mois dernier
ouais il y en ai pas vus 0e ce cash
c'est normal c'est les théories ne crois
pas qu'ils vont créer un seul tour dans
l'aéroport
si vous étiez une tortue clair les
chatouille ah bon je vous étiez mort un
crime passionnel
bravo